[Music]
hi everybody and thank you for joining
my talk before we start
okay
a little bit about myself I mean data
scientist the Dell I work for the
storage and Service Groups mainly with
time sales data on a lot of cool
projects if you want to know more come
to me later
and the pastor worked for a healthcare
startup with a lot of sensors tracking
your daily activities and if you drive
in a dangerous way and I'm also a new
mom to Ali who was born three months ago
so I didn't sleep for three months
so hopefully for for you you will
understand something
so what are we going to talk about today
uh we will start with guns famous
supplications then we will go to the
fundamentals of Gans what is a generator
what is a discriminator and the min max
game we will talk about evaluation
methods and finally I'm going to talk
about the use case we did a Dell that
used gun to solve the problem at hand
now this stock assumes you have no
knowledge of guns so I'm going to start
pretty from pretty basic stuff and I do
assume you have some knowledge in deep
learning
okay so this is a tweet from Ian
Goodfellow with regarded as the inventor
of gas and chosen the amazing
progression from 2014 was very pixelated
black and white photo
to uh 2018 was a quite real looking
image of uh someone that do not exist
and it keeps progressing this is from
style Gun 2
images of faces that of people that do
not exist and they look real to me
another cool application is image to
image translation this is from the
pix2pix gun paper
which take an image from one domain and
transform it to a different domain so
for example here we have a sketch of a
handbag or sketch of a shoe transformed
into a photorealistic photo
image sorry and the way the model is
trained is by using paired images so we
have the data which is the sketches and
we have the labels without which are the
photorealistic images
we don't always have the option to have
data labels so for that
there is the cycle gun which is doing
quite the same takes an image from one
domain transform it to a different
domain
for example you can see a Monet painting
transformed into a photorealistic window
to some of Summer to Winter zebra and
the style of horse and vice versa but in
this case
the model doesn't have to train on pairs
of images but rather two sets of
images from different domains a lot of
zebras a lot of horses and the model
knows to transform the style
and super resolution gun I think it's
very useful and you might have heard it
about it already so it takes an image
with low resolution
and gives you a generate for you an
image with higher resolution a sharper
image
so this is again
um
an example from the paper on the left
you can see the original image in the
middle you can see a down sample blurry
image and on the right you can see what
gun generated for you which is pretty
simple to the original one
and finally text to image games now text
to images are hot very fashionable topic
today with a lot of Delhi and imagine
and stable diffusion this is not the
state of the art this is from a paper in
2016 and I think these are really pretty
neat results for that time the model
here was trained on three different data
sets birds flowers and Ms Coco each
image got five different text captions
and you can see for example on the top a
man in a West suit riding on a surfboard
on a wave background truth is on the
left and the generated image are on the
right
well if you want to have fun with
generated stuff go to this x does not
exist and you will be able to generate
feet eyes horses resumes and a lot of
cool stuff to have fun with
so this is it for the application and
let's go to the actual games
and before that let's start with the
difference between generative and
discriminative models so a little bit of
intuition the screen discriminative
models will learn the decision boundary
between different classes so if we have
data of dogs and cats the model will
learn to differentiate between them
and generating more models they learn
the probability distribution of the data
or they have the ability to generate new
instances of the data
and more formally or mathematically
speaking
so given a set of data X and the level y
discriminative models they learn the
conditional probability probability
given X an image
what is the label and generative models
learn the opposite conditional
probabilities given and
a label the model learned the
distribution let's say of how do images
of dogs looks like and can generate an
image of a dog
okay so what is the main idea of gun gun
is basically a two players game that
competes against each other we have the
generator you can think of it as the
artist who try to generate or paint
images for example of cats that looks
like real cats and on the other hand we
have the discriminator which you can
think of as the art critics
it sees a lot of images of cats and it
needs to designs if these cats are real
images or fake images meaning they are
images generated by the general so this
is really a pretty high level
description of Gan and let's dive into
each one of these models separately
okay so discriminator discriminator is
just a classifier that has two classes
they have real and fake class it's
usually in the vanilla gun it's a neural
network it could be a CNN we fill it
with an image and the output is a
probability a probability for being real
so the mass notation is here as well
given X the model learned the
probability for this image to be real
and what is the process of learning we
have we start with X which is the image
we feed it to the discriminator
discriminator gives an output as a
probability
and this probability together with the
label is fed to a cost function now we
are going to talk later on on the cross
function but what you need to remember
from here is the goal the goal of the
cost function is to penalize the
discriminator
for failing to differentiate between
real and fake images that's the goal of
the cost function here
let's go to the generator
generator goal is to generate for us
plausible data samples or images it
looks like real images so we start with
a fixed size Vector a random noise
usually taken from the gaussian
distribution we feed it to the network
and the output is actually an image
not actually an image
so just a little bit of intuition of how
the generator learn generator learn by
getting feedback from the discriminator
so if you can see on the right on the
left here generator will start with some
nonsense image it gets a feedback from
the discriminator this is nonsense
and then it keeps improving until it
generates image that that can fool the
discriminator basically and it looks
like a real image
and the process of learning we start
from a random noise the fixed size
Vector okay we feed it to the generator
the generator outputs for us an image
this image is fed to the discriminator
that again outputs Progressive
probability for how much does it think
this image is real this probability
together with a label is fed to the cost
function so again before we talk about
the cost function the goal what you need
to take from this the goal of the cost
function for the generator
is to penalize the generator for failing
to fool the discriminator because the
generator job is to full the
discriminator
okay
so let's say we had a discriminator in a
generator basically the end goal is to
save a good model the generator that can
generate for us images we feed it with
fixed size vector and the model generate
for us images
so let's just have a small recap before
we move on
so we have generator discriminator
discriminators is both real and fake
images fakes those are generated images
and outputable abilities that is fed to
the loss function of the discriminator
on the other hand we have the generator
who generates say examples that are fed
to the discriminator and the output of
the discriminator which is a probability
is felt to the generator loss so we
talked about about a lot about the loss
and what is the goal of each loss so
let's see what is the actual loss okay
this is going to be I think the only
math in our presentation but it's a
beautiful
loss function also called min max loss
or binary course entropy loss and let's
Dive In
we have the first term which is the
prediction of the discriminator
on real data and we have the second term
which is a prediction of the
discriminator
on fake data
so let's
go over the notation okay X is a real
image and D of X is the prediction of
the discriminator uh probability on real
data now the discriminator wants this
probability to be as high as possible
because it means with high certainty
that it sinks that real image is
actually real
so what happens in the second term
let's go over the notation first so we
have z z is a fixed Vector that we start
with okay we feed it to the generator
and it outputs G of Z which is a fake
sample okay this fake sample is fed to
the discriminator okay which gives uh
which outputs a probability for how much
does it think it's real it is real
so let's zoom in on this D of G of Z
okay and I understand it better
discriminator once D of D of Z to be as
low as possible because it means that it
thinks with high certainty that this
fake image is actually fake but the
generator wants this quantity to be as
high as possible because this means that
it managed to pull the discriminator
discriminate of things this is the real
one
and this is basically what sets the
adversarial game the game between those
two um
desires of the discriminator and the
generator now one last thing is why are
we using one minus D of G of Z
this is because we want to set
both the desires of the discriminator
and the generator
consistent between these two terms now
we are getting an
a loss function that the discriminator
wants to maximize those two terms and
the generator wants to minimize
and this is basically we have an
objective function and we need to find
the discriminator that maximize this
objective function and it generator that
minimize it
and so hopefully this made sense and I
want to show you a little bit of code on
how gun training works and before that
let's just have again a small recap on
the training I always find it a little
bit confusing so I'm going back to it
every time so we have a discriminator
and a generator that that are trained in
an alternate fashion okay so again you
saw this before but I'm going back to it
we have the discriminator that is seeing
real data and fake data when I say fake
that is data generated by the generator
and outputs probabilities those
probabilities together will label unfair
to the cost function that we just
discussed okay then we calculate
gradients and we update the network this
is for the discriminator we objective
the discriminator on the other hand we
have the generator again generate Fair
example for us those fake sample fell to
the discriminator that outputs a
probability for us this is fair to the
cost function which is the mean Max cost
or binary cost entropy here below and we
calculate gradients and update the
network
so
let's look at some code to describe it
so by touch to the win
we start with importing some
relevant models okay then we instantiate
the data set which is just the way
to read the images and do some
transformation on them like if you want
to resize them we want to turn them into
tendo normalize the pixels Etc then we
instantiate again the data loader which
is again a way to load the data during
training uh is it going to be in a
multi-processing way or what is a batch
size or is it going to be shuffled or
not
and then we finally instantiate the
models we have the Net G which is the
generator now these are predefined
classes okay I didn't put it here
because we don't really have time to go
over all the code but I I have a link
here to the full collab
a notebook you can take a look or just
go to the documentation of titles on
guns
so we instantiate the discriminator and
the generator
we instantiate the loss function we also
discussed the binary course entropy loss
function then we have the labels one for
real data and zero for fake data and
then we instantiate the optimizers
optimizers is a way to update the
weights both of the generator and the
discriminator
and then we decide which device we want
to work on and we're going to train on
GPU
spoiler yes or CPU
so this is the most important part I
think again not the full code but
describe pretty well the training okay
so on the left this is a training and
update of the discriminator and on the
right it's the training and update of
the generator
okay so we start iterating
on the data with epochs and uh here with
we are zeroing out a previously
calculated gradients from the network
uh we move the data to the device we
want to work on again we create the
labels here the labels is just a tensor
of one's for real data
okay we fit this real data to the
discriminator
uh net D and we get an output as
probabilities okay those probabilities
together with the label are fed
um
into the loss function and we calculate
the gradients and update we calculate
the galleons for real data now what
about fake data quite the same we start
with fake noise okay sorry random noise
taken from the gaussian distribution
then we have uh we feed it to the
generator and we get fake images
um those fake images are fed to the
discriminator okay
um and we get probabilities as output
the probabilities together with the
labels are fed to the loss function
and we calculated gradients with
backwards and finally we update a z
discriminator
okay the generator is pretty similar
okay we are zeroing out the gradients we
create labels
we feed those this fake data to the
discriminator
and then we have we feed the loss
function with the output of the
discriminator of on fake data and labels
calculate the gradients and
finally we at this stage we update the
generator okay so again if you want to
see the full code and and try to play
with it
um I can give you later on the link or
you can go just to
documentation
okay so we talked about training we
talked about the loss function we talked
about generator discriminator and we are
left with how do we evaluate results
when we have them
so two things that are important one is
Fidelity okay we want the quality of
images to be in good quality looks like
real images and the second is diversity
we if we create images of dog we want
different breeds different types
different colors
Etc
so how do we actually evaluate it
quantitatively okay so one way to do it
if we are a real image of a dog and fake
image of a dog let's do some pixel
distance
that could give us a good estimation of
how much they are close but the problem
is as you can see here with the pixels
the image on the right is shifted uh
um
to the left so even though if you have
two images that are similar and one is
shifted then the distance will be high
and it will not represent how close they
are
a different way is to actually look at
features of the images okay we have a
real dog with eyes a nail and nose and
we have a fake dogs that also have eyes
ears nose but five legs and this can
give us a sense of how close they are
so the question is how do we extract
those features
so we have
pre-trained classifiers okay so they are
a lot of famous architectures that are
trained on imagenet which is a
collection of more than 14 million
images with more than 20K categories and
those
um those models are pretty good at the
extracting features from images in the
earlier layers the extract features like
edges or shapes and in the last layer
they actually get to specific features
like eyes or nose or face
and there is one famous architecture
which is called Inception B3 we are not
going to dive in just remember that we
are gonna get from it a vector of 2000
and of the size of 2048.
so we have an image we feed it to
Inception V3 and we get the embedding of
the image which is just a feature
representation of this image and what do
we do with those features or with those
embeddings of the images
so there is a family score called for
sure Inception School
originally The Francesco was used to
measure the distance between two curves
or two probability distribution and in
this context it is going to measure the
distance between the distribution of
real embeddings and fake embeddings now
the below there are other scores that
are important to know and I'm not going
to talk about inception score and
precision and record
uh but for sure is what we are going to
discuss so let's talk about how we are
going to use for sure so let's say we
have now a generator well-trained create
for us images and we want to measure the
results
so we samples a lot we sample a lot of
fake images from the generator and we
sample from our training data real
images
and we extract the embeddings of those
images and guests the mean and
covariance for the real embeddings and
mean and covariance for the fake
embeddings and finally we
calculate the Francesco which is the
formula below this takes the distance
between the two and
means and the distance between the
covariance trace is just the sum of the
diagonal of The Matrix
now what you need to take from this is
lower FID is better because this means a
distribution of real images is close to
the description of generated images
okay so we discussed evaluation training
generate or discriminator let's talk
about Dell
so
let's describe the data we have user
logs from different systems that Dell
specifically this is from dell.com you
see the nice laptops on sale
and example of your user session is like
user logs in browse add to cart go to
home page and then check cell
the task at hand a bell was given user
activities so you want to predict what
is the next
um
user activity going to be
so let's say we have a story of four
activities model wants to predict what's
the next activity out of a pool or we
had 120 activity so this is basically a
classification task that we have at n we
had at hand question is what guns has to
do with that
so we use the nice paper that is
actually using a guns with lstms that
are networks that are specialized with
sequential data so there is a generator
which is an lstm that generate for us
fake user sessions and there is a
discriminator again an lstm that gets
fake session and real session and decide
what is fake and what is real
now let's elaborate a little bit okay on
the top we have a real user session okay
login browse that took out home page
remove from cart then we fit to the
generator the forward first activities
and the generator products for us the
fifth one in red
so when we have the prediction we are
now creating real session we'll use a
session and fake user session okay so on
the top we have real user session
because we have the training data and on
the right we have the force the four
first activities and the fifths which is
considered to be the fake session
this uh both fake and real are fed to
the discriminator and this is how the
discriminator decides what is real and
what is fake
eventually what we were interested in is
a well-trained generator a generator
that learned the probability
distribution of user sessions at
dell.com we feed it with a user history
and it gives us
um
the next the next activity of that user
so before we end I just want to give you
kind of a summary to to what we had at
the beginning of the lecture and what we
had at the end okay
so we discussed uh guns for images and
then we discussed gun for sequential
data so for images we the generator will
start with random noise fixed size noise
and in our case we started with a
sequence of user activity okay
the second difference is the model
architecture the vanilla gun or other
gun architectures are using neural
network or cnns and in our case we use
lstms and finally evaluation we
discussed FID for images and in our case
we used a weighted accuracy in F1 in our
case it was easy because we had the
label as the next activity from the
planning data and we had the prediction
and one last thing about result or why
we use gun we obviously tried a Baseline
lstm and then decided to go wild with
gun and gun surprisingly improved our
result significantly and
yes that is it
so if you have any questions
okay yes
you mean the business use case what what
do we need the next activity so first of
all it was a POC because they cared
about
um
specific actions like if the user is
going to to ditch the website that was
the first case and the second case was
some activities like if user wants to
pay then we it that their website moves
you to a different application and it
takes time for loading so if we know
about it in advance and logic time is
it's a better user experience okay
[Music]
well we did that as a Baseline and we
just wanted to try and
a different approach to see if I can
improve it and to tell you why guns
improved it I have some speculation I
don't know I saw nice results in the
paper you know I was fooled by it I
tried and it worked
yes
yeah it was quite big but this was uh we
we had the limited data for the POC case
but it was I don't remember the
exhaustion a lot of something hundreds
of thousands of Records or a hundred of
Southern records yes
sure what why are you clapping in the
background
[Applause]
yes do we still have time or okay one
more question yeah
please oh
okay
the prediction was being made for a
reason the user is about to draw
but that's the prediction that you're
going to try and change their behavior
and show them something else yeah
but as soon as you put that in does that
confuse the model does that uh
invalidate the prediction
uh this is a good question I must say I
must be honest and say say that this
stated the POC level not because it
wasn't good enough but for other reasons
but I didn't try it to tell you if it
confused the model enough but it's a
good point to take when it's actually in
production
okay one less right okay yes how is the
performance in comparison to other I
would say more conservative models that
just predict the next step so I can't
say like specific numbers but we try the
Baseline of Valencia vanilla and we
tried that and I saw significant
Improvement I was surprised to be honest
I didn't know I will get such
Improvement but it did so I took it
okay thank you
[Music]